[Music]
all right people I am officially back on
the grid this week and joining me to
make some sense of the world that I
missed is host of the aptly titled
philip defranco show right here on the
YouTube Phil DeFranco I love that I love
that you've put that on me of trying to
make sense of whatever the hell it is
we're living in right now well I have to
tell you you have a lot of pressure on
you because I I could have selected
anybody for the beginning of season
three I'm back on the grid
I lost my razor I'm trying to figure out
what happened and for some reason I
chose you
I'm loving this though I'm just jealous
I know that was saying it before but I
want to go on the record I'm just very
jealous of the facial hair I feel good
about it maybe maybe you could grow out
a little something oh no I can grow out
a little something a little something
it's not a actual something yeah but
you're a respectable guy and you're
you're doing videos every day mm-hmm do
people want to see you change your look
I don't I don't know if I want a pretty
consistent look over the years yes i all
i do is i fluctuate sixty pounds
depending on the stress level of that
time because i will say i'm so glad the
timing worked out but i was still a
little iffy on doing this because i know
that side angle and I don't like from
the side and that was like that was the
50/50 coin flip of if I do this or not
that's hilarious so much I was like yes
well so okay so there's a few things
going on here so one of the reasons I
wanted to have you on was just to catch
me up on some of the stuff and I wanted
it to be from somebody that I think is
consistently trying to be honest and and
do good stuff but you are an insanely
busy person it turned out that we live
literally within walking distance of
each yeah which is almost impossible in
LA and yet we were trying to connect for
like a year and it couldn't happen when
it finally did you got in your car and
realized that it was a half a second oh
yeah cuz I never actually go on this
specific street yeah
and so I'd gone off the highway and I
was like oh oh what and for a second I
thought I was getting like pranked right
I was like okay I'm just driving home
yeah but uh yeah no it's crazy but
that's also I think that's very much la
like it doesn't matter where you none of
us lay exist in the real world we just
were point a point B right there's no
we got some people some normies walking
around the neighborhood being outside
living life well I'm God or you now for
the past month but yeah I mean for the
most part I'm in one place or another
yeah you are a busy guy because all I
did for the last month when I was here
beside was doing some writing and some
garden but I was walking my dog a lot
and I kept thinking I'm gonna have to
see him at some way cuz I'm walking
around for hours aimlessly never but it
proves my point that you are you're a
busy guy yes well I'm trying to make a
lot of cut
yeah well the goal is to make more like
I definitely so right now we put out
across the two channels 8 videos a week
but the next the big next step that
we've been kind of building up to the
launch of is a daily one hour live show
just finding the right people to be
involved what I've done in the past has
been more comedy first and then news was
attached to it for me now the next step
is is news first and then make it
relatable make it funny but that's
that's a second thing because I think
people need to be informed or at least
informed of what other people are saying
yeah yeah so as if you're not busy
enough just with the show you also have
a second child do I believe in two days
from two days unless your producer gets
a phone call in which case I will have
to hop out of this but the record I was
willing to let you keep the phone in
front of know it's which we normally
don't do but you said no no no if the
baby's coming the baby can wait wait
what it's very important no but your
phone is in there in case some don't
have cause it could happen yes
why are you ready for a second one yeah
it'll be great and it's also it's an
excuse to take a week off so that I can
be home try and make some normalcy in
the you know over the beginning of the
chaos but I'm excited but two and done
two and done no more don't want to be
outnumbered two is great fair enough so
for people who don't know you yes well I
mean I'm on YouTube - right but there
might be somebody here that that doesn't
know you plenty people they don't know
you what what possessed you to start
talking to the camera being really
really being really bored and in college
I've been on YouTube now for over 10
years anytime I mention who I used to
watch back in the day 1% of my audience
knows who I'm talking about but it was a
lot of talking heads and I think it's a
lot of what's people
feel today and why they jump into where
they see some people that may be doing a
good job but they think they can do as
good or they want to be that great or
they think they're garbage way better
and that's and that's kind of how I
jumped into it and I wanted to talk
about the news because I just wanted to
talk to someone about everything that
was happening right that's it's I've
always been like a very like a loner
kind of loser type stuck to myself the
close I get to talking to someone like I
I found myself trying to jump into
things like Magic the Gathering cards so
I just had someone to talk to about
something because now a lot of people
wanted to talk about news in high school
right
so yeah just really bored really poor in
college started making videos talking
about current events
pretty much anything back in the day to
chase the front page but it was always
it was always news I was always
conversation but that's really it when
did you realize that it was actually
like becoming something more than just
like taking care of a little lonely I
like to think that it's it's right
around the time that I dropped out of
college because I was at this point
where my grades are starting to fail I
was realized I was blaming YouTube for
it but I was my heart really just wasn't
in it anymore
I had for like seven years my dad told
me like you're gonna be a doctor and so
I was in the pre-med program and I hate
that I hated it my brain did not work
for that skill set and and then one day
right when I was about to quit YouTube
YouTube gave me a call and inform me
about the partner program right kind of
kind of like this why were you gonna
quit you know because you thought it was
affecting your grades so yeah you were
trying to yeah well at least yeah that's
what I was thinking and then the moment
I realized and they said I wasn't making
a lot more money than I initially was
right and so I was like oh well screw
this like I I'll just I'll just focus on
this I'll drop out it'll be fine and it
was not fine initially I had you know
just figure out a way to make it work
for for several years and then I think
once I once I finally found myself in
California with with some of like the
old faces shaycarl kmg Danny diamonds to
start maker that's the moment I think I
realized okay this is this is like a
real thing
this could be a real real thing it's not
just me in a room by myself this is this
is the rise of something new do you look
at that with a certain amount of
nostalgia now like sort of like the good
old days like a little bit one kind of
knew what was happening you didn't
realize whether this was gonna be a
money thing or a career thing or what
and just everybody didn't have a handle
on how big this all could be I think for
me it's it's never really
so obviously the money is fantastic the
money is an enabler and I will I will
not talk on money but for me it is
it is really what we're putting out
there right yes I put out I put out
vlogs and that's like it's supposed to
be entertaining in some sense give
people behind the scenes of the
personalities that are working on
something but that's also just my
attempt to reach out and talk to someone
about something that's not news the the
other bit it's just it's just especially
now it's just so important to talk about
what's happening because everyone's so
confused and frustrated and so I'm
that's one of the reasons I left maker
early days it was it was business first
mm everything else second right my bank
account would look slightly different
but I'm so glad personally as far as the
work and what I'm doing that I decided
that I want to do it my way that every
move that I've done while money might
have been a part of it that it's always
been about what is the end result of the
content we could make or what we want to
make sometimes some of that some of
those things did not fully get fleshed
out but it's why I'm still doing it ten
years out and I don't have to it's
because I really love this and I really
care about it yeah and you've had some
business ups and downs and bumps and
bruises along the way and you just kind
of kept doing it and now you're fully
independent which yes just from
everything you just said I mean it's
like it's sort of like the greatest
thing that you can have as a creator
right it's so it's the best thing in the
world to be independent but you also
lose one thing right and that's the
ability to blame someone else right I
don't like to blame anyone that's
underneath me because their mistake is
my mistake right you put people in
control and that's ultimately like
that's you the net result is you so I
don't get to do that anymore but the
upside this is the 99%
that's great yeah how much do you find
that having the business part of this
and being the the head of the company
and all that do you like that or do you
find that to be that it takes you away
from the stuff that you really care
about that creating that content right
at times I especially when I initially
launched and we were setting everything
up and you get into the kind of like
that okay this is I'm remembering what
it was like to be back in college and
and staying at Panera Bread for way too
long and I was like doing everything
myself and being on every phone call and
there's a point where that's a rush and
then at about a year a month and a half
it's like okay so I'm ready for I'm
ready for this a new step and so like
that's even something we're still
growing right so right now one of our
newest hires is gonna be our new CEO see
you oh yeah CEO Oh someone that can just
make sure that everything's working as
intended grows the company for us while
I'm in hopefully the more creative
sessions yeah where do you want to go
with all this like what's the now that
you're independent and I see it just
it's just grown and grown and grown and
I think you've hit something that's very
sort of similar to what I've tried to
build it around here which is just like
it really I think the secret is just
basic decency like when I watch your
videos you strike me as fundamentally
decent and I feel like that's just kind
of yes and you also and you have a
commitment to the truth and you actually
are trying here both sides and all that
stuff but I think underlying that is
just kind of like a decency you know I
think the the one of the biggest things
that I've always found and it's
something my dad taught me when I was a
kid is even when you're disagreeing with
someone try try your best even no matter
how you how much you disagree with them
and and and and everything that they're
saying give them leave them with a door
open right to save some face to maybe
realize that part of what they were
thinking there is a misstep there
because when you put someone in a corner
although you're really confirming or or
all you're really doing is locking them
down in their belief right I I've been
there right when in in the past if I've
been talking to someone and they hit me
with something that proves like
something I previously thought was wrong
it almost feels like I'm being I'm being
like attacked
I'm being told I'm stupid and it's not a
great feeling so when you're arguing
with someone right if the real intent is
is to to hopefully promote truth right
hopefully promote the right thought
hopefully then you're leaving the door
open for them so you're saying that not
screaming at everybody that they're a
racist and a bigot and all that that
might not work but we're all guilty of
it I see you or sometimes I say
something about like the left right
absolutely and it's easy to talk in
generalities right sometimes you have to
talk in generalities on certain subjects
but sometimes we get a little swept away
with it and we end up causing the same
problems that we say were fighting
against yeah I I find it and what sucks
is we're doing it openly on the Internet
in this in this grand experiment so
every time you falter everyone sees it
right and more importantly you see it
and it's just there and so hopefully you
don't do that thing that I just said
where where we then just lock down and
we're like well no there's a I'm
different for some reason that we grow
from it it's hard it's painful but I
think you just have to keep trying
you're gonna fail a lot but keep trying
yeah and we all make these mistakes and
it's interesting I don't remember what
the specific instance was but you did a
video on thinking it's time to do with
the terror attack or something and I
jumped the gun on neither the name of
the guy right I don't remember the
specifics if you do feel free to say it
but but I liked the fact that you you
said I like Dave Rubin he well you know
screwed this one up or whatever you said
and I actually liked it cuz I was like
yay I did do it you didn't accuse me of
doing something that I do I screwed up
something I did correct it once I found
out but but often when you correct
things that gets much less traction than
the than the original thing that's a
whole other problem of social media all
that but I thought your intention wasn't
to mock me you were showing that even
people that you like right screw up
sometimes and I feel like everyone
always wants to pretend that they're so
infallible and it's just silly and it's
important I think it's important that
people know that we are all infallible
but also that if we're going to point
out all the flaws of mainstream media
that we don't then just repeat the same
mistakes that were criticizing right
they're not perfect I think the reason a
lot of people get angry is
there are people in the industry that
see themselves as higher right you see
it every time there's there's someone
that writes about a youtuber and a very
disrespectful light like we're all just
nothing yeah right we're this like this
fad even though this is the like the
swing of the new normal
right even if if CNN had the numbers
that you had they'd be thrilled I mean
if you shut CNN off at airports whatever
their numbers would be Philip defranco's
do you know I'd be interested damn close
let's put it that I think I mean I think
most a lot of the the up and comer is
definitely beat the the mainstream
outlets as far as the 18 to 35 as far as
full numbers I don't know your talk
about an international company I like to
puff my chest up I know I know but I
always have to like bring myself down
well at least in terms of the influence
that I see from from what I can garner
online and what the conversations are
about and people that are talking about
the right things if I was to watch 10
minutes of one of your videos on what
happened in the world versus watching 10
minutes of CNN say doing another poll
about Trump it's like I actually learn a
lot more so you have a certain amount of
by doing good work you've now put
yourself in a position where there's a
lot of pressure on you to keep doing
good work yeah and the time I feel the
most pressure is any time I meet people
they go to an event or for some reason
I'm in a public setting proof for once
in a long time and people are like
you're the only person I watch which one
I will always say please watch more
right please taking more sources but
then like that makes me feel so horrible
about off days where I'm like you know
what I got two hours to sleep again I
was like we're gonna try and do like an
eight-minute show and it's it's a day
that I personally feel like I let people
down even no matter what the numbers are
online I personally feel it well I tell
you about the the state of things that
people say that kind of thing to you
well I think it's like we were saying
earlier that people don't know where to
go or they just want they do want a
voice to bounce off of but they they
want a voice that they can only also
respect that they don't see themselves
as always right but I also think that by
only posting like only posting 10 to 18
minutes a day as a main show I have an
advantage over the mainstream outlets
who do have to do 24 hours
right so it's the reason why you have
CNN talking it's talking about that like
a plane crash for weeks and weeks and
weeks to the point where you have
someone talking about the theory that
the plane went into a black hole right I
don't have to we're not that desperate
that we're taking crazy as real like
yeah that maybe would be in the 19th
minute you know yeah that's that's what
happens when it extends yeah what do you
make of just a general situation on
YouTube right now there there's a lot of
people very frustrated with YouTube from
creators to people watching people are
feeling
you know this whole D monetization thing
which you've done a bunch of videos on
there's a feeling that there's some
censorship being involved happening
right now I don't know if you noticed
this one I mentioned it on my live
stream earlier that we now have videos
you know for this month that I was gone
we had videos in our backend that were
not tagged not titled they had no
metadata attached to them and they were
demonetized yeah that's something that
we noticed specifically on our vlog
Channel like really not on the philip
defranco show which was a very strange
we had a video where we were just
standing around talking Auto flagged we
change we changed the information
multiple times I mean this is like it's
not a unique story it's it's so weird
and confusing and I don't get it
do you have any contact with the YouTube
people I had so much I mean it took me
literally two years to finally I did the
one work thing I did last break I got
one phone call with them I got no
answers I put this on youtube
I want this to work you know what I mean
like yeah I'm not sitting here so we can
just talk about them like I want it
to be a better product right because
this is how we get our stuff yeah we
criticize the things we love because I
wanted to be better I totally get that
no I've had so I've had the same contact
at YouTube for about seven years when
you said that they were gonna
potentially offer someone from their PR
department to talk I was like who is
that yeah well they can be a name yeah
okay no cuz I have a person and I talk
to them I get information from them a
lot of it ends up being stuff that they
haven't cleared to be on the record so
if you get a source that is willing to
talk publicly yeah that'd be great
because otherwise all we get are people
having to talk to their partners
and then YouTube uploading some video
they don't realize is condescending and
everyone gets angry yeah right well you
know we had this back-and-forth going
out at them because people kept telling
us they were being unsubscribed from our
channel and we saw the growth just
didn't make sense and we got an email
from someone there saying yes there is a
bug on your channel or looking into it
and then like the next day they put up
that video remember that like six months
ago those two like oh I love it like no
it's never happened before we have no
evidence a great question you know it's
it's so frustrating it's so frustrating
sometimes it's it's easy for it to feel
so personal but I think that there's so
many moving pieces there are times where
people don't realize things I've talked
about certain things on the show and
then talk to people at YouTube and
they're like we didn't know that was a
thing on the site that there was a
problem yeah and so I try I try whenever
I can to also message them before I
cover a story not to give them a heads
up but just to go like if there is
something like an explanation
I'd love I'd love to be able to include
it but it is so frustrating especially
because for most people it's most of
their income right because they haven't
diversified or they haven't I saw your
new shirts focusing on merch or having
some sort of alternate thing and I mean
the good end is if you have a good
product then you can use that as a way
to then convert audience that really
care about the content but otherwise
like you just right now you just
yeah well that's why I think and that's
why I asked you the question about the
business side and how much you put into
that versus the creation because I think
for me it's actually by doing this and
as you know you're in my home this was
my garage and now a studio like the
things that I talk about I'm sure I've
been able to put into practice the
beliefs that I have I've been able to
put into practice into the business so
it's more like the more that these if
YouTube closes a door on me on this or
whatever it's like yeah in life you just
got to be smart and go where the next
thing is right or else do you care how
people watch or where people wanna it's
a well especially thanks to like the
patreon and the Franco elite I don't
care right if they if they watch we're
gonna start may be uploading smaller
videos to Twitter as well just to get
the most traction everywhere but if
you're watching on Facebook
you're watching on YouTube great if we
then jump to another platform fantastic
I always treat my videos like a shiny
thing or like he's right and just I want
to leave those things everywhere so no
matter where you turn it's right there I
don't know about your numbers because
it's longer form yeah but most of my
views are now mobile mobile or iPad or
every now and then it's like there's
like a there's been a jump for like X
boxes and Smart TVs but the like the
numbers for computer are at an all-time
low
yeah do you think an offer could be made
to you that would swipe you up no hey Q
do it no no we were we were having a
conversation recently I was trying to
explain why I couldn't do certain things
and why I would never sell again and
when people hear that they hear
something that's emotional right they
hear something that's like never again
it was it's not like I'm suffering from
from some sort of thing it's just I
don't like the feeling of not being in
control right so you could say okay well
that means just hold on to 51% but I
have a different mindset about it
because with this launch so much of it
was fan funded right and I'd feel like
I'm giving that to someone else rather
than putting it into the content
there are justifications where you could
say well by getting this person it
affects the content maybe maybe I'll
evolve on that I don't think so yeah but
no never never again do you ever have a
moment where you think oh I could say
this thing or cover this topic that
could actually now half my patrons might
be pissed at me or no or leave or
anything like that no I think that's one
of the benefits of trying to cover
everything as honestly and try and try
and convey other people's points of view
is that I mean every video I'm offending
someone right and and that's like it's
strange to hear for some people because
there are people that are like phil has
never had like a opinion that people
disagreed with which is an insane thing
to say alright that's like going well
everyone thinks this one thing I've made
people angry and that's fine my hope is
that I've formed a relationship with
people where it's it's okay to do that
that I'm your friend or that person that
you're friendly with that you talk about
stuff with that you don't necessarily
agree with that's that's my goal and
what's kind of great about that is yes
I'll always be shedding like some
subscribers I'll always be shedding some
some patrons but if I'm doing an
effective job I'll continue to grow over
time yeah and so and so that's if
anything it's made me feel more
comfortable that there are that number
of people that that were that were
supportive enough to go like I might
disagree with you but let's do this yeah
isn't that so also the beauty of fan
funding in general whether you're doing
it on patreon or anything else it's like
if I wanted to sell out to my audience
or whatever that is I would I truly I
would not even know which way that meant
well well I say when you say sell out
what's your mindset because a lot of
people have a different mindset around
it does that mean no no sponsors does
that mean no yeah I mean look we have
sponsors on our audio podcast which by
the way we didn't do for three years on
rest and we finally did to make up some
of the YouTube stuff we only accept ones
that I think are actually you know worth
worth except right but at this point I
feel very much what you said there I own
and control and operate my own business
the way that I want to it's successful
it's growing all of those things I don't
know what package could ever be put
together yeah I could make more money
but I'm not in it for that like I'm
doing all right so it's like I don't
know that something could supersede that
beautiful thing that we have you know
yeah it's like what every artist is
fighting for all the time in the history
of the world
and and we have it for you know
hopefully more than a brief moment it's
beautiful yes I have nothing everything
you said is a gotta Mecca
you
[Music]